hello everyone i'm john l chudge and
with me
virtually is my good friend and
colleague amos miller
we're excited to be with you for this
webinar on microsoft soundscape
heads-up and hands-free experiences for
everyone for now
sit back and enjoy the video and we'll
join in about half an hour for the live
q a
during the video though we will be
monitoring the chat window for any
questions so please don't hesitate to
get started
okay welcome to the soundscape webinar
i'm amos miller i'm the product
strategist for
microsoft soundscape and i'm joined here
by my friend and colleague jarnell
judge johnel and i are the co-founders
of soundscape in the enable team
in microsoft research
my interest is in technologies that
augment
and augment human perception and
the sensory interaction with the
environment
with a particular interest in people in
experiences
for people with disabilities and
different abilities
okay so here's the game plan um
i'm going to start by introducing the
challenge that our work on soundscape
is attempting to address and walk you
through some of the
key elements of the solution to give you
a good sense of what it's about
i'll then hand over to jonell and he
will walk you through the way that we've
developed
soundscape in the wild with users
he'll discuss some of the really
fascinating discoveries that we made
along the way
and how we developed some of the
principles that guide
the soundscape experience
and then we'll look forward and ask what
does this mean
for the future of human empowerment and
technology
so a lot to cover
this work started with a big question
the large majority of people who are
blind or low vision in the world
really do not enjoy the same level of
freedom as everyone else
and even with all the great technology
that's around that is still a big
challenge
and we really set out to explore how can
we
tap into advancements in technology into
new research in hci a new understanding
of motor neuroscience
to make a material difference to people
when they're out and about to people who
are blind when they're out and about
really look at how technology not only
help with navigation
but help them gain a sense
of independence when we
at the heart of this quest uh there's a
set of words that we use to characterize
the experience
presence awareness
flow um
words like agency human agency and
control
and we we may not be aware when these
characteristics are present
but we surely do know when they are not
present
imagine for a moment when you're driving
along
you've got some quiet classical music
playing through your stereo
your kiddo is telling you about a
difficult day that they had at school
today and then bam your gps comes in 100
meters you have to turn
left now you're faced with a stressful
moment
working out what that last instruction
meant and how you interpret it
and that magical moment is gone
yep we do know when that experience
breaks down and we also know
that it doesn't really have to be that
way and that's what this talk is about
as a blind person when i'm out and about
i do want the technology to help me
navigate and feel more confident out
there
but i also wanted to empower me to be
more aware of my environment
to be present with the people that i'm
with
to feel a great sense of empowerment
so let me first walk you through how
what soundscape
is and then we can dive into how we
address these challenges
so the idea with soundscape is that we
use
3d spatial audio to help you build
a richer awareness of your surroundings
when you're out and about
spatial audio is really cool technology
that with stereo headphones
you can place sounds and audio cues that
they sound like they come
from the environment rather than inside
your head
so for example wearing a stereo headset
with soundscape on my phone
i can walk down the street and if
starbucks is coming in front of me
on the right i'll hear the word
starbucks
over there where starbucks is which is
really cool
and i can hear exactly the direction
that it's in
um if i walk up into an up to an
intersection
i'll hear the name of the road on the
left way over there
on the left not in my ear or inside my
head but way over there on the left i'll
hear one in front of me
i'll hear one on the right so i get the
layout of the intersection as well as
the names of the road so i can make my
navigation decision
let's run a brief video to give you a
sense for what that experience is like
um the video is not going to be in
stereo so you won't hear spatial but
we'll provide links to the video so you
can watch it afterwards as well with
stereo headphones
hello and welcome we are going to
demonstrate how i use soundscape i have
my friend
emily here with me hi there and my guide
dog trevor
you're going to hear and experience
soundscape in the same way that i do
through these headsets so let's go
facing north along 101st avenue south so
emily where should we go
i heard there's a place called local
burger nearby would you like to try it
let's do it i'll set a beacon to it now
i can
hear the beacon over in front of us and
to our right that's where the local
burger is
excellent that beacon's really helpful
as i can't see past these trees
fantastic so let's go there all right
instead of step-by-step instructions
soundscapes lets me
hear where the destination is so i can
make my way there
mainstream coming up to an intersection
goes right
crossing here's the crossing listen to
the traffic
we're safe to cross all right and it's
safe to cross
hey here's franz chocolate over there oh
perfect
we should set a marker there on our way
back now i can hear the beacon loud and
clear on my right so we'll turn right
amazing along it comes right in front of
us so we know we're walking
straight towards it
on main street and straight towards the
beacon
we're gonna start hearing it coming on
our left as we get close to the local
burger
joseph dory build it on me
and you can close by i could see the
door
ah here we are fantastic
emily thank you thank you and uh thank
you for listening
okay so there's a lot going on here
let me break it down uh soundscape is
running on the phone and it knows the
person's location
in the direction that they're facing and
it draws data of them from the map
to work out what's in their surroundings
and then
through the stereo headphones it
it it's able to place the callouts
in 3d i work in msr actually about on
spatial sound and head rotation
transfer function that was led by van
taschev
has been a very foundational component
of this work
and the headset is a really important
piece here
first of all we look for good stereo
headsets but importantly
headsets that don't block the
environmental sound so you can
hear everything around you while hearing
the augmented sound
we also love head tracking headsets
these are headsets with sensors that
track your head movement
and that enables us to improve the
3d image significantly by tracking
small head movements and also to ensure
that the audio stage remains stable when
you move your head so for example if
starbucks is over there and you've
turned your head at 45 degrees in the
other direction
starbucks doesn't turn with you
folks who are familiar with neuros motor
neuroscience
will recognize how this mechanism
leverages active
inference in multi-sensory input
but put simply our brain is just
unnatural when it comes to hearing
spatial sound
in the environment and using it
for awareness and for movement and
navigation
the soundscape app is available on the
app store for anybody
to use and we encourage you to go and
try it out
it's quite different from other
navigation
apps but it's really simple and a lot of
fun to use
you just put your stereo headphones on
start the app
and walk you'll you'll immediately start
to get
call outs in 3d around you
if you want to head somewhere
specifically you can search for that
location you set
what we call a virtual audio beacon to
that destination
and instead of turn by turn directions
you'll hear a bell emanating from that
location
so that you know where it is and you
make your way there
and you'll notice when you walk it
doesn't demand your attention in any way
you can remain
present in your surroundings in your
conversation with a friend
yet still be fully aware of where you're
headed
so how and why did we arrive at the idea
of using
sound in this way let me hand over to
journal judge
to share some fascinating insights thank
you thank you amos
hi i'm john l church and my background
is in design
and research what particularly motivates
and inspires me is designing
empowering sustainable and inclusive
experiences which enhance human
awareness
and which not only allow us to do more
but actually be more
so as amer said how why did we arrive at
using sound in this way
well ultimately it comes down to the
importance of getting out into the real
world
with real people and seeking to
understand right at the point of the
experience
exactly what is going on and through
that design method
identifying gaps and possibilities and
opportunities
and it was during one such research
visit in the temple in area of london
as these photos from the visit go to
show there's quite a group of us
courtesy of the guide dogs ngo in the uk
we have some guide dog owners
some orientation mobility specialists a
local
travel guide and of course a mix of
researchers designers and engineers from
microsoft
we spent the day immersed in the
experience
and it's only a couple of days later
when amos and i were reflecting on the
visit that we recalled
a particular fountain it's in the
central picture a lovely little fountain
in a courtyard
and it suddenly dawned on us that we
always knew where we were
in relation to it because sometimes we'd
hear it ahead of us or to the side
or coming from the back and because of
that we always had our bearings
even if at the time we weren't fully
conscious of that
and it was that experience and the
impression it created
that led us to really double down on
looking at how we could use sound in a
more natural
and effortless way
it was really then that we threw
ourselves into the design process
focusing on a range of different end
user activities but always in the
context of that end-to-end experience
we ran a series of workshops with a
diverse group of participants a little
like the research visit
but this time with each workshop getting
tighter and tighter on the attributes of
the experience
and the scope it was highly iterative
and dynamic
we'd go down a particular route get
really excited about something
and then whatever it was didn't quite
sink or feel right
and then we'd go back but by allowing
some time between each workshop
we gave ourselves a little bit of space
to reflect to reimagine
digest and absorb what we were doing and
come back to it again
and slowly but surely the experience
maps the broad spectrum of people that
we were considering
the actual interactions and information
needed at any given step
all started to come together
and unusually for us actually our
deliverable in the first instance was a
15 minute movie
and we set it about five or seven years
in the future back when we actually did
it
and we called it a family day out
because we wanted it to be about the
normal
everyday activities of life in this case
organizing a day out in london
our central character bill actually
played by a blind actor
is organizing it for his young son and
his elderly father-in-law
and over the course of the movie as
shown by the different scenes on the
slide here
we see bill deal with and handle a range
of different situations
from travel disruption they take a
picnic in the park do a spot of shopping
they visit the natural history museum
all the things that you'd expect really
but importantly he's using technology
naturally
and effortlessly and above all the
spatial sound that we've created
is allowing him to be independent and
engaged and enriching his relationship
with the spaces and the places that
they're in
throughout the whole day
one unusual artifact from doing a movie
was actually writing a script for every
scene every interaction from the
perspective of the different characters
it's not something that we typically do
in ux or design
but it really forced us to think hard
about every word and every action
and how we tied it in to what it wanted
to convey it's a great way of actually
pairing the content down
to that which is absolutely essential
however we think that what really set
this apart was that as a side project
to the movie we were determined to
establish the feasibility of spatial
audio
and remember this was a good few years
ago and it's all very well depicting
getting a positive light in a movie
but we wanted to feel confident that the
technology itself that we were
portraying was capable of coming
together to deliver the experience that
we were depicting
so we did a hack way before hacking
became the phenomenon
it is now so we got some big
over-the-ear gamer headsets we attached
some sensors to the top of it
so we could track the movement of the
head we attached those sensors to a
circuit board
encased inside a little metal biscuit
tin as you see in the photos here
and finally that circuit board was then
tethered to a laptop held by another
person
not particularly portable but with it
we're able to create this spatialized
sound experience outside our offices
and amos was able to take a walk from a
bus stop to the entrance of building 3
something he had never done before all
guided by
sound so
inspired by the movie and the prototype
and the momentum that was beginning to
build around the work
we set out to build a technology for
real i sketched out a scope that
involved a person
traveling from the house in a
residential neighborhood making their
way to a bus stop
traveling on that bus into town where
they would catch the train and they get
a bite to eat
as part of the first phase of work we
created this small corridor between
reading which is a small city to the
west of london
and london itself which we then
instrumented with data
and sensors and beacons and buses a
whole host of things so that we could
have an end-to-end experience that we
could validate
and we work closely with a number of
internal and external collaborators to
put it all together
and as we did one thing that was
foremost in our minds was finding the
right balance between the human
experience
and the technology we knew that the
technologies that we were working with
weren't yet quite ready for prime time
they weren't yet generally available
and not designed to do some of the
things that we wanted to do with them
but we hacked our way around some of
those challenges and reminded ourselves
time and time again that whatever we did
always strive to keep the that soul of
the experience intact as emma said
earlier
about being present about being in the
flow and to that end
as a team we immersed ourselves further
in the experience of a blind traveler
we spent countless hours with mobility
specialists
and produced this enormous physio sheet
which ran i think about 10-15 meters
wide
and for every single step of that
journey we atomically broke it down and
for each step there were 12 or so layers
of information
that provided a contextualized richness
that really was quite unique
and as we completed phase one we worked
with researchers at guide dogs to
validate the end-to-end experience
as per the uh the slide so there were 17
measures in particular that they were
interested in
to do with orientation mobility
cognition physiology and so on
and we had eight participants take part
and they were able to go deep and do a
before and after analysis of their
experience
so firstly without the soundscape
technology to begin with
and then a week later those researchers
took those same people out again but
this time with soundscape
and after 17 measures they found that 10
had shown a significant increase
and that the remaining seven had either
shown a slight improvement or remain the
same
so from our perspective that was great
it's probably the best we had hoped for
however it was analyzing their verbatim
feedback
that really acted as a challenge to us
in terms of what we did next
sure spatial audio provided a richer
experience which
every person enjoyed but it was their
feedback
that it made them feel more confident it
made them feel more connected and more
present
that really made us sit up and take
notice it was those feelings and those
sentiments that we felt we had to
understand
and deliver through soundscape so
in phase two of the work we did a
complete about turn
on the paradigm that we were designed to
experience to we realized that we were
making the experience
better along already well known roots
but for us
we felt that true empowerment could only
come through a travel and being able to
go where they wanted to go
on their own terms and not being reliant
on anyone else
so we moved away from the initial
prescriptive turn-by-turn instructions
that we're providing
i focus instead on providing a
description
of a person's environment so with
soundscape as i must describe this works
beautifully because the callouts of
these places
come from the direction where they
actually are in relation to you
so you just naturally almost innately
begin to build an awareness of your
surroundings
and with that mental map that's
beginning to form that confidence just
emerges to be able to go where you want
because you know if you take a wrong
turn you'll just be able to recover
and make your way back and make your way
back to a known place
so in phase two we invited 12 people
into reading eight of these participants
had never been to the city before
and all of them within the space of a
couple of hours were able to make their
way around from the train station
to a department store a cafe then across
town to the town hall itself
and every one of them was able to
accurately describe
the spatial relationship between these
different places
it was amazing i mean we saw their
confidence visibly increased throughout
the day
we saw them becoming more spontaneous
they're so much more willing to explore
and learn about these new places
and we felt this was it this was
soundscape
so moving on i'm going to talk a little
bit about some of the work we've done to
help us better understand the value that
soundscape can bring
and the way we approach this was through
the lens of accessibility and
inclusion so clearly accessibility is a
responsibility
enforceable by law in many cases there
are over a billion people in the world
who have disabilities
many of whom need assistive technology
but only one in ten
of those people have access to the
products they need and this means that
they can't fully participate in our
economies in society
and accessible technology can allow that
participation to take place
and we know that disability is something
that can affect any of us
someone we love at any time whether it's
permanent
in the case of a permanent with one arm
for example
temporary if a person has an arm injury
and is using a sling
or situational as in the case of a new
parent holding the baby in one arm
the experience is the same but
accessibility can also be seen as an
opportunity
to develop and apply innovation that
levels the playing field for everyone
so research in this case from accenture
indicates that organizations which are
inclusive and
value accessibility outperform their
peers
by quite a way so 28 percent higher
revenue
double the net income and a profit
margin that's 30 percent higher
bottom line accessibility and inclusion
just makes good business sense
so what have we been doing to help
realize and demonstrate that opportunity
for soundscape
so being guided and informed by the
building blocks of the soundscape
experience about enhancing awareness
keeping you the person in control
allowing you to engage and connect
through
this innovative audio experience so one
of the aspects that really driving us
is a desire to better understand the
value that our customers and our
partners see in soundscape
and in spatial audio in general and
based on that we've actually embarked on
a few adventures of our own
so currently soundscape is all about the
outdoor experience
but of course the indoor space beckons
as well
we did a proof of concept about a year
or so ago
at king's cross station where we
integrated soundscape with an indoor
position technology
to guide a person independently around a
very busy train station
we learnt a lot from that experience in
particular the value that indoor venues
such as shopping centers
supermarkets transport hubs etc all
place
creating a richer and more engaging
experience and as
the indoor positioning technology
continues to mature we see great
potential for soundscape to contribute
to that space
so on this slide here our work at
skyview visitor attraction stockholm was
really quite unique
here we worked to create an audio
experience that used the familiar
soundscape beacon
to guide a visitor to a landmark that
they had chosen on the stockholm skyline
and then once they were directly facing
it they heard that
uh familiar uh bell sound
but then we virtually transported them
as if they were there
so imagine that the uh they've selected
the royal palace
and they could directly hear what it's
like during the changing of the guard
ceremony
so you're in the middle of the crowd and
you can hear the chatter chatter all
around you
over to your right the trumpeters are
playing over to your left
you hear the name of the horses it's
just as if you're right there
that's real 3d immersive audio that
allows people to connect with places
in a new and different way to experience
something that they hadn't
really ever imagined
we've also been doing a lot of work in
the area of adaptive sports
so what initially began as a hackathon
project a couple of years ago is now
turning into something that is allowing
our partners to create their own bespoke
experiences
here they were using soundscape while
paddling
making their way around the water with
their
companion just enjoying the sun and
spatial audio
and non-verbal cues don't compete with
our cognitive ability
to attend to a conversation or to a
complex task such as paddling at the
time
ironically or appropriately in many ways
each person was able to remain present
and in complete flow
we had a lot of fun doing this work and
here's just a little snippet from the
first time
we introduced it to a group of
volunteers cindy
smiling and full of joy coming back to
shore so
much fun i really appreciate the whole
soundscape team
having all of us out today i'm happy to
be a part of
a movement and that is to help all of us
live more independently
and full and rich lives hey
to you now johnel thank you that was
wonderful
um we began the talk by looking at these
characteristics of the experience which
john
touched upon presence awareness
flow agency and you know you can see
clearly that these are relevant to a
whole range
of experiences in human situations
i mean we're all too familiar with uh
the phone taking our attention away when
we're out and about
or sitting around at the dinner table
with our family
even in navigation we actually recently
published
an essay in scientific american
where we discuss how soundscapes based
audio guidance draws on our
basic human skills for navigation
and in fact does a better job with
awareness and mental mapping
as compared with turn-by-turn directions
we also all spend a great deal of time
in remote meetings these days in front
of a cluttered screen
with voices that are mixed together and
you can barely know who's speaking
you know with spatial audio you can
separate these voices out
you can feel more present with the
people that you're in the meeting with
and stay in flow and not constantly
distracted
augmented reality technologies they
bring
huge potential to our human experience
and draw on our ability to imagine
we actually recently added a beta
feature
to soundscape that we call street
preview
where you can transport yourself to
anywhere in the world
and experience the area in full
spatial audio virtual reality
it really is an amazing experience it
engages your whole
body and imagination
when we think about the devices that
make
their way into the fabric of our
experience
we want these devices to support our
human experience to amplify it
not replace it or dampen our engagement
and this calls for further research in
areas such as
uh human perception
attention how we manage attention and
our awareness
questions that are related to agency and
the characteristics
of a technology that ultimately makes us
more human john
thank you amos so to sum
things up a little bit we'll share some
of the key things that we've learnt
through our journey with soundscape
and what it may mean for evolving
product and service design and
research so firstly this has been
greatly aided by the multidisciplinary
and diverse team
that we have wonderful collaborations
with internal groups across microsoft
and with so many of our customers and
partners as well and also the amazing
mentors that we've had and continue to
have who have guided us along the way
from a creation point of view the
experience really is
everything to get out into that world of
your users learn who they are
what they do what matters to them
because it's only at the point of the
experience that you'll discover
just how diverse that whole ecosystem is
and the context in which any particular
interaction takes place
and then we can design for that so we
were fortunate too that the opportunity
to make a real difference to real people
provided a natural sense of purpose
and working within the constraints that
we imposed actually acted as a catalyst
for innovation
it created the space to explore and
investigate and rapidly evolve our
design thinking based on what we learned
and as we've seen time and time again
sometimes
designing for the edge case often in the
area of disability
provides innovations for everyone we've
seen it with door handles
dropped curbs magnetic zippers and so on
and now perhaps you can add soundscape
to that list
so here this is a wonderful image isn't
it a group of people crossing an
intersection
while heads down on their phones so
whether we're out and about or at home
or at work
having our heads buried in our phones
we're messaging playing games browsing
social media
usually oblivious to our surroundings
and the people that we're with
something i think that we can all agree
is all too common
and all too familiar we all do it yes
often we don't like ourselves for doing
it
but we think that with soundscape there
is a different way
what we feel that soundscape is allowing
us to do is is to tap into our innate
human potential and our desire to
overcome our limits and grow
one where we're fully attentive to what
we're doing or being aware of what's
going on around us
so we've actually covered a lot of
ground in this webinar and we hope
you've enjoyed it and are excited by the
potential of soundscape as we are
and it feels like we're only just
scratching the surface of the power of
sound
we know how important it is and how it
makes us feel
the energy it creates and how it
connects with our other senses
and we also know the importance of
creating silences of gaps
for the sound and the meaning to come
through
ever so slightly biased i know but
soundscape really is quite a special
experience
an experience that we feel instead of
reducing
will amplify and augment our
capabilities as human beings
and getting closer to that vision of a
heads-up hands-free experience
that feels natural and just flows with
you
so on behalf of amos and myself thank
you now please do stay for the live q a
with amusement myself which will open in
a second or two
hello again thanks for attending the
microsoft soundscape heads-up and
hands-free experiences
for everyone webinar and now to the live
q a so
we said before i'm john l church and
with me is uh
amos and we're also joined by our
colleague emily green as well
who has been looking at some of the
questions as they've been coming in and
over
the next 15 minutes or so we're going to
be answering uh some of the ones that
have been submitted by the
audience so yeah we'll get started and
the first question
we do get this a lot is where we
soundscape currently available
and uh i i can sort of uh
take that uh soundscape's been out for a
couple of years
originally we launched in the uk and the
us and
over the last couple of years we've
since released and made soundscape
available
in australia canada sweden
france brazil and very recently italy
and our plan is to actually bring it to
more countries more places
over the next 12 months or so i think
one of the
uh reasons and this leads to the other
question that
was also posted because it was such a
new technology we initially decided to
focus
on on ios and as that feedback
has been coming in and we've been
growing and refining the soundscape
experience
we get asked about availability in
android and this is certainly something
that we're looking at unfortunately we
don't have a time frame that we can
share just yet but rest assured we are
looking at this and
it is part of our ambition to make
soundscape available to
everyone um everywhere um
another question uh aims i'm going to
hand this over to you
is to do with sort of head tracking
a question was from adrian lawrence
and he asks is head tracking already
supported for the end user experience
on the ios app and would it be supported
by a proprietary headset
thank you johnel um this is a great
question
we talked about the importance of stereo
headphones
in the overall soundscape experience to
augment the
environment around the person and really
be able to
place sounds in 3d
relative to where you are and where
relative to where locations are in the
environment
and indeed the ability to
head track as in to
monitor the direction of the head and
position the sounds
relative to the direction of your head
rather than just the body
it really takes the experience to the
next level
we've been working with a number of
organizations
headset manufacturers to kind of
stimulate this
category if you like of headset
capabilities today
uh the ios app supports head tracking
with the airpods pro with the apple
airports pro which
about uh six months now are
offering this capability um the early
the first iteration of the bose frames
both alto and bose rondo also
have head tracking sensors the later
generations at this stage do not support
that capability
and that's an area because of the real
effectiveness of that experience it's an
area that is really uh taking uh
building up momentum right now brilliant
now thank you
uh thank you very much i'm actually
going to pass on another question
from adrian to you as well
he asks binaural cues might behave
differently
for different people due to
psychological differences so
and this might affect the perceived
location of
the virtual beacons the ud beacons that
we use in soundscape
so are there options to personalize the
3d audio rendering
which is it's a great question
so it's a really great question and
that's um
an area that we we spend a lot of time
in
there is it currently in the
in soundscape we don't offer
personalization of what's called
hrtf which is the matrix that helps you
adjust the sound based to your
individual needs
um for a variety of operational reasons
more than anything else
but what we what we do do in soundscape
is what we call double in code we add
additional information so for the for
people who don't necessarily hear the
full spatial sound
um maybe they may be due to hearing loss
maybe due to different
uh um other other characteristics or
even some
people choose to use the mono speaker
from the phone
so we build into the sound additional
cues so that you can still
detect the direction for example of the
audio beacon by changing the
the percussive nature of the beacon as
you
point towards it or away from it so
that's it's a great question
multi-dimensional uh challenge
and we try to optimize for for the range
of needs in this
space brilliant thank you uh amos
uh we have a a a great question from
john drake as well
he asks what do you see as the next
steps evolution of soundscape and where
will it be in say
five years time and i'll take a first
step at this status and then uh
be good to get your thoughts because i
know this is something that we often
think about talk about as well and in
many ways i think we hinted at it a
little bit towards the end of the
video in the the webinar where we see
enormous potential
for this technology in particular the
ability that it provides as we
say to have a heads-up hands-free
experience
we recognize we're not there yet but
we definitely feel that that is the uh
the vision towards which we're working
and
the capabilities and the experiences
that were
designing for are all ultimately
intended to help us accomplish that goal
and why is that so important to us it's
important because
it allows us as humans then to be in a
position where
we're able to express ourselves without
technology
getting in the way a technology is there
to support and aid what we want to do
but it's not hogging the limelight it's
not the center of attention
it's allowing us it's providing the mean
through which we can express ourselves
and with the vast amount of information
that
increasingly is available our ability to
be able to tap
onto that contextually in a way that's
relevant to
where we are and what we're doing we see
that
as having enormous potential for
not just productivity but for a whole
host of enriching human experiences
all the way through to creativity to
expression
through social experiences and and so on
i could carry on for a long time but i'm
going to hand over to uh
to amos i don't really have a great deal
to add john
other than to agree with what he said
and to really you know
imagine that you do walk walk down the
street
and that device that enhances your
awareness and keeps you connected
to your environment into your digital
life is just not that thing that
drags your attention and pulls you away
from your conversation with your
child as you walk down the street but
instead empowers you to be
more human i don't think it's out of
reach
um and i think i think we have a lot of
evidence and experience to show that
audio actually has a real potential you
know the audio field
is so much wider than the then the
field of vision and there's so much more
we can do with it that
i think it's a really untapped potential
and we just
see those experiences uh developing
uh and and the required technologies to
support that
and yeah we both feel really fortunate
to be able to work in this space where
we do have the opportunity to
explore this whole gamut of potential
new experiences and what it will mean
ultimately to human awareness
and human consciousness and so on so
yeah this is
very very exciting we are very fortunate
another question um that was in the uh
the sort of channel
was um recently there have been a lot of
announcements around spatial audio
and usually to do with uh entertainment
um and whether it's listening to music
or watching movies and so on and of
course soundscape is all about sort of
navigation
wayfinding uh i guess is the term that
we uh prefer to use
uh a muslim invite you to take this
uh what do you see as the sort of
differences the parallels the
similarities
uh between this and what potentially
does soundscape have to offer here
i think first of all uh it's what we are
seeing
is evidence of spatial audio as a medium
as part of a design experience of the
des
of an experience starting to make it
into the mainstream
up until now i mean the one of the first
applications of special
audio has been in fighter jet pilot uh
cockpits so you can hear multiple radio
channels concurrently and decide which
one to attend
that's a very niche and very expensive
application
and the fact that we are starting to see
spatial audio making its way to some of
our
more mainstream day-to-day experiences
is going to float all boats and it's a
really really
important progression i think in this
technology space
media entertainment television that's
definitely an area that we've all lived
in spatial audio but
we required large and expensive
equipment to do that
and now with a pair of headphones you
can achieve that
soundscape in the wayfinding and
exploration and general awareness when
you're out and about you can call it
augmented reality
or the augmented reality as is the space
that soundscape is really pushing
into um and that applies
in in that can apply in a range of
scenarios that
that we talked a lot about in the in the
talk
um so yes i think that this is an area
that i i
urge and and we always enjoy hearing
people's ideas and contributions about
how
this medium can be applied to a range of
scenarios
okay and thank you amos and i'm just
going to ask you to double back to a
previous
uh question from adrian where it's just
asking
to elaborate a little bit further about
what you mean by double encoding
and for example would a sound be
reaching a listener by mixing together
the 3d binaural and traditional stereo
playback mode
what i meant in double encoding is for
example
[Music]
we we still play the sound in binaural
sound um but we also add
for example if you listen to the beacon
with soundscape
if you are aware not not if you're not
pointing at the beacon you'll hear a
certain
type of sound and as you head to the
center
the texture of the sound changes and
until you hit the middle and you get a
actually a bell reinforcement
um and that's deliberately designed
in order to that's what i meant by
double encoding we have
you can we could just play the sound
without any other any changes to the
sound and then you are totally reliant
on hearing the spatial sound with that
additional double encoding you can hear
the spatial sound but you can also you
also get
additional reinforcement and you can
also only use that reinforcement without
hearing the spatial sound
there is you know one may require more
cognitive load than the other
um and our our experience shows that
that if you hear the spatial sound and
get that full experience
you can really park it to the periphery
of your consciousness
and not pay any deal any great deal of
attention to it and that's that's the
ideal experience but there's definitely
other
other ways to to receive that
information
amos i'm just gonna ask you to elaborate
on this further by talking about
uh i guess the way that we approach and
think about
sound design and audio design in
soundscape and why it is
so important to us and maybe some of the
things that we've tried to
incorporate into the sound design itself
yeah i mean if you're going to live in
sound then the
experience that you have or the origin
of it is in sound and it's really
interesting that
it's so hard for us to stop looking at
the screen
well not for me because i'm blind but
for the sighted people
you know every feature that you start to
work on
uh the the the impulse is to go and
figure out what the screen flow is going
to be and which buttons you have to
press and so on
and in soundscape we really say hold on
let's start from the other end let's
start from
what is it going to sound like how is it
going to
address the need of the user in a
particular situation and what is the
flow of the sound going to be
so it is
supporting the experience the minimum
minimum
interruption so that it doesn't demand
attention or demands as little attention
as possible
um that the handoffs between one step
and the next step
flow well for the user and only once we
nail that
flow do we start working back backwards
from that
and figure out okay how these are going
to initiate that experience how they can
personalize that um and and so forth
we really you know we try to use
non-verbal cues for example where
possible which
are uh they require very
they don't require mental processing if
they
are really natural and easy to interpret
uh we try to maximize the use of the
spatial sound where possible again
so that people can hear but not attend
to what they're hearing if they don't if
they're in the middle of a conversation
of something else
with somebody else so a whole range of
these
nuances and considerations that we uh
spend a lot of time uh finding as we as
we work through the
design in soundscape and yeah and i
guess just to sort of add to that we
don't purport to have cracked it
for us this is as much a learning
experience as it is for
the folks who are using soundscape and
the feedback that we get helps us to
continue refine
and and improve that experience by by
learning what people are doing
out there in the the real world um
just a couple of other areas i wanted to
sort of uh cover off
uh as well um it was a question about
sort of computer vision
there's question about the sensors that
are increasingly coming to devices
and what role do you see potentially
soundscape having with that
in the future i'm so gonna
pass that over to you
yeah i mean anything we can get hold of
to get a bet for the device to get a
better sense
of the environment around you
and the information that you might
want to have the more the merrier
and our our job is to ensure that you
receive it
and process it in the way that is most
effective
for you um so indeed i mean
computer vision is uh is a very is an
obvious
uh space to to start leveraging and
other sensors like
lidar and other capabilities that are
really starting again to make their way
into the mainstream and don't require
absurd level amounts of power
i mean one of the things that we care a
lot about in soundscape is
is that it's accessible to as many
people as as possible
and that it uses the underlying
technologies that people can get
and we and realistically use it wouldn't
help if if we use something that drains
your battery within an
hour unless it was for very specific
moments
so we take all of those uh sort of
trade-offs into account
as we work with the team and other
members in the microsoft research group
and in academia to really understand
what are the possibilities uh that we
can
enhance this this uh this space
great thank you looks as if we've got
time for just one more question today
which is uh
i guess what excites us most about some
of the work we're currently
doing and i'm sort of happy to take that
and they must have you
uh add to it as well i think one of the
areas that
we're really excited by is we hinted at
it in the
presentation is the work that we're
doing with um
that's designed to enable uh the
collaborators that we work with service
providers
so for instance we're working very
closely with the orientation and
mobility community
we're working very closely with adaptive
sports we're working very closely with
service providers in a range of
different environments and sectors
if you will and ultimately working with
them to look at how they can bring
soundscape to
their landscape their environment the
service experiences that they're
responsible for
and ultimately thinking about it in a
way that allows
others to create their own soundscape
expired experiences
amis anything to add to that
yeah i mean we we do this because we
we are excited with what soundscape is
doing with people when we
when people first use soundscape it's a
very
new experience they put it they put it
on they put the headset on they kind of
look a little bit puzzled
until they get it and all of a sudden
that huge
smile comes onto their face because it's
something that
is until you feel it you don't
quite realize what the experience would
be like
i mean then we get then the things that
you can do with this kind of
of input in this kind of
way of conveying information i
do dabble i would say in adaptive sports
in kayaking
and downhill skiing and so on and the
possibilities that the ability of
sound guided experiences
or sound guidance rather to help to
enable me to
be and feel independent
feel have that sense that i'm the one
that's driving
that's steering the kayak or deciding
how to zigzag on the
on the slope of the of the of the
mountain that
that's that feeling that we always
aspire to and get
excited when we see it happening in in
the real world
well thank you i was just going to
squeeze in one more question from
anessierre banerjee um and she's
wondering about the future possibilities
of augmenting soundscape
explicitly for hearing aid and cochlear
implant users
and just to sort of very quickly respond
to that
it's a great question and yes ultimately
we do see
future trends where existing devices
will have additional sensors and the
ability to be incorporated
into with soundscape we think will
enhance that experience even further
we know that some of those capabilities
already exist
and we do anticipate more and more of
them becoming
more and more mainstream so with that
thank you all for attending today we
really appreciate your participation
and interest in this subject questions
that you've
provided us with have been excellent and
if you're interested in learning more
we do hope that we've got the list of
resources
sent out properly inside the the chat
window now
and we look forward to seeing and
hearing how you build on this
research and evolve the space of audio
ar
ultimately we hope in support of
amplifying the natural human
capabilities that we have and creating a
whole new set of experiences to empower
everyone thank you